I'm at Bub's Burgers and Ice Cream just outside of Indianapolis...
...to attempt the Big Ugly Burger Challenge.
Finish one one and a half pound burger and I get my picture on the wall of fame.
But it doesn't have to end there.
Two burgers, I get a headshot,...
...three burgers, I get a poster on the wall,...
...and four burgers gets me a life-size cutout.
95% of challengers finish the first Big Ugly.
20% take down two.
Only three people have done three.
And in 42,000 attempts, no one has ever demolished four.
Today, I'm here to make Hoosier history. So, anything less than four Big Uglies is a loss.
Opened in 2003, Bub's serves up ice cream beside an escalating lineup of burgers...
...none more massive than the 22 - ounce Big Ugly.
Okay, now you are big and handsome,...
...yet this is the Big Ugly.
Oh, it is ugly.
At your hungriest, could you do more than one of them?
That would be tough.
That would be tough but it tastes so good, I would try it.
How do I remain photogenic in the face of all this beef?
Give me some beauty advice.
Give me like a sexy pose.
Maybe work it.
I ate three burgers.
"Man Versus Food", all new, Wednesdays at nine, only on the Travel Channel.